i wonder
not just about planet nine i wonder if
that's kind of the
future of doing science in our solar
system
is to just launch a huge number of
probes so like a
whole order of magnitude many orders of
magnitude larger
numbers of probes and then starting for
a bunch of different stuff
not just gravity but everything else so
in this regard i actually think there is
a huge
revolution that's to some extent already
started
right the standard kind of like time
scale for a nasa mission is that you
like
propose it and it launches i don't know
like
150 years after you propose i'm over
exaggerating
but yeah you know it's just like some
huge development
cycle yeah and it gets delayed
55 times like that is not
going away right the the really cutting
edge things you have to do it this way
because you don't know what you're
building so to speak
but the cubesat kind of world
is starting to um you know provide an
avenue for like you know launching
something that costs you know
a few million dollars and has a
turnaround time scale
of like a couple years you can imagine
doing you know phd theses
where you design the mission the mission
goes to where you're going and you do
the science
all within a time span of five six years
that is has not been fully executed on
yet but i
absolutely think that's on the horizon
and we're not talking
a decade i think we were talking like
this decade yeah and the company is
accelerating all this
uh with uh blue origin and and
uh spacex there's a bunch of more
cubesat oriented
companies that are pushing this forward
uh well let me ask you
let me ask you on that topic what do you
think about
either one elon musk with spacex
uh going to mars i think he wants spacex
to be the first
to put a first human on mars and then uh
jeff bezos gotta give him props
wants to be the first to fly his own
rocket
out into space so you know wasn't there
a guy
who like built his rocket out of garbage
yeah this was like a couple years ago
and somewhere in the desert
he launched himself i'm not tracking
this closely but
i think i am familiar with folks who
built their own rocket to
try to prove the earth is flat yes
that's the guy i'm talking about yeah he
was also like he also jumped some
limousine
yeah for truly revolutionary minds
uh greater men than either you or i
but uh would so look it's been
astonishing to watch how really over the
last like
decade the commercial sector
took over this uh you know
this industry that traditionally has
really been like a
you know a government thing to do um
motivated primarily by the
the competition between nations like the
cold war sure and now it's
motivated more more and more by the
natural forces of capitalism yes that's
right so
um okay here i have i have many ideas
about i think on the one hand
right like what spacex has been able to
do for example phenomenal
um if that brings down
the price of spacex within that
turnaround time scale for space
exploration which i think it inevitably
will um that's a huge you know that's a
huge boost to the
to the human condition the same time
right
if we're talking astronomy right there
they're also
it comes at a huge cost right and the
starling satellites is a great example
of that cost right at one point uh
in fact i was just camping and the
mojave was a
with a friend of mine and they saw you
know
this uh the string of satellites just
kind of like
you know appear and then disappear uh
into nowhere so that
is beginning to interfere with you know
earth-based observations so
i think it's there's tremendous
potential there
it's also important to be responsible
about how it's executed
now with mars and the whole idea of you
know exploring mars
right i don't have like strong opinions
on whether a manned mission
is is required or not required
but i do think you know we need to focus
the thing to keep in mind is that i i
generally kind of
uh i'm not signed on if it will to the
idea that mars is some kind of a safe
haven that we can
you know escape to right
mars sucks right like living on mars if
you
if you want to live on mars like you can
have that experience
by going to the mojave desert and
camping and it's just like
it's it's just not a great well it's
interesting but there's something
captivating about that kind of mission
of
us striving out into space and by making
mars in some ways habitable
for at least like months at a time i
think would lead to engineering
breakthroughs that would make
life like in many ways much better on
earth like it would we'll come up with
ideas we totally don't expect yet both
on the robotic side
on the food engineering side on the
you know maybe like we'll switch from
wha like they'll be huge breakthroughs
and insect farming as
as exciting as i find that idea to be
that in you know our in the ways we
consume protein maybe
uh it'll revolutionize we do factory
farming which is
full of cruelty and you know and torture
of animals
will revolutionize that completely
because of our like we don't
we shouldn't need to go to mars to
revolutionize life here on earth
but at the same time i shouldn't need a
deadline to get [ __ ] done
but i do need it and then the same way i
think we need
mars there's something about the human
spirit that loves that
longing for i i agree with that thesis
the going to the moon
right and the that whole
endeavor has you know
has captivated the imagination of so
many and it has
uh it has led to incredible kind of
incredible ideas really and probably in
non-linear ways right not like okay we
went to the moon
therefore some person here has thought
of this and yes
in in that similar sense i think you
know space exploration
is there's something there's some real
magnetism
about it and it's on a genetic level
right like we have this
need to keep exploring right when we're
done
uh with a certain frontier we move on to
the next frontier all that i'm saying
is that i'm not moving to mars to live
there permanently
ever you know and i think that you know
i'm glad you
paid you you noted the kind of
degradation of the earth
right i think that is a true kind of
the leading order challenge of our
entire great engineering that's
a bunch of a bunch of engineering
problems
you